c'est bien et
ça aurait pu être fait avant c'est
surtout ça pour présenter sa carte de
de fidélité pour avoir deux
deux portions de cinq matches oui il
faut présenter la carte pour en obtenir
la carte de fidélité
donc c'est dur pour ceux qui n'ont pas
la carte parce que tout le monde c'est à
dire c'est pas une obligation d'avoir
une terme de fidélité
une fois qu'on a fait nos courses on
passe aux caisses et on demande si on
veut un masque ont aussi on veut pas moi
j'en ai pris deux passes pour moi et
pour ma fille tout simplement mais de
toute façon je crois pas qu'ils donnent
le plus à ces 5 par personne c'est des
petits paquets de 5
donc c'est raisonnable et c'est
distribué par personne c'est bien parce
que d'un petit donc tous les puits on
peut acheter sauf en france on veut pas
nous acheter juste aujourd'hui nos
petits chanter en allemagne un peu on
peut pas tout acheter sauf en france on
vous le dit voilà c'est bien il faut
demander dans les caisses sont pas en
libre service à 123 5 mars le nombre de
paquets mais il aurait fallu le faire
bien bien avant c'est scandaleux
je pense que c'est un peu le parcours du
combattant puisqu'il faut demander aux
caissiers aux caissières de voilà de
nous donner des masques mais je ne sais
pas par combien et je ne sais pas
comment mais voilà je pense que c'est au
compte gouttes quand même si on ne
trouve pas ailleurs
je viens on mange on m'a donné que 5
on m'a donné un joli mais c'était sa
coupe à courir c'est ce qu'a demandé à
la caisse mais ça coûte 90 centimes la
masca vous faites le contraire c'est
même pas sans convoquer